foreign
[Music]
UPS everyone including cios Business
Leaders and even the media but then
there's you who has never heard about
Phoenix or maybe you've heard about
females but I'm not quite sure what he
is and if it even matters but don't
worry that's why I'm here my name is
dumibioti and I'm a phoenix consultant
at Google and in this video I'll be
telling you all about Phoenix and why
you should care about it especially if
you work with Cloud technology
so let's Dive In every year Ghana
releases a hype cycle for emerging
Technologies reports that lists the most
known technologies that are set to
impact business and the society for the
next decade and in 2022 for the first
time augmented phenops which is a
component of finops was listed as one of
such Technologies along with other
Technologies like web 3 AI and machine
learning so now that we know that
phenops is sort of a big deal what
exactly is it here at Google we Define
finops as an operational framework and
cultural shift that brings together
technology business and finance to drive
Financial accountability and accelerates
business value realization through Cloud
transformation to break that down even
further with traditional I.T that is
before organizations started operating
in the cloud I.T calls for the
responsibility of the I.T Finance team
or in some cases the procure commenting
span was predictable and it was easy to
stick with the budget set during the
annual Cycles but the cloud has changed
everything for example an engineer can
easily sit in the comfort of his home
and spin up a cloud resource that could
cost a thousand dollars without getting
the approval of I.T Finance or the
procurement so the discipline of finups
provides a new way for teams to manage
their Cloud costs where everyone takes
responsibility for their Cloud usage and
this is governed by a central team
finops is sometimes called Cloud cost
management or Cloud Financial
engineering or Cloud cost optimization
but in reality the discipline of synapse
goes beyond just Cloud optimization
there are five reading blocks of synapse
accountability and enablement
measurement and realization cost
optimization planning and forecasting
and tools and accelerators
[Music]
accountability and enablement focuses on
establishing a centralized
cross-functional team whose
responsibility is to set governance and
standards to manage Cloud costs across
the organization measurement and
realization focuses on developing kpis
and business value metrics to track the
success of cloud transformation because
optimization focuses on identifying key
cost drivers providing visibility and
making it a continuous process to
constantly optimize Cloud costs applying
and forecasting focuses on properly
allocating Cloud costs and deciding on a
proper showback or chargeback mechanism
finally bringing everything together
tools and accelerator focuses on using
the right Cloud cost tools to properly
allocate and effectively track Cloud
spend so now that you know what cloud
Phoenix is here are three reasons why
you should care about Cloud Finance
number one cloud finops is here to stay
and favors the early adopters the
earlier you get started the better for
your organization number two with the
recent economic fluctuations phenops is
a tool for organizations to optimize
your I.T technology and help them get
the maximum value from the cloud lastly
cloudfinops is a critical tool to
accelerate digital transformation if
your organization is interested in
getting started on their freedoms
Journey do send a message to the email
in the description
thank you and I'll see you again in the
next video
[Music]